hello and welcome to
a live q a here at the economist my name
is anna bucks i'm a video journalist for
the films department
and today i am joined by john pete who
is a political and brexit editor
at the economist and we're going to be
discussing all things brexit
um thank you very much to all of you who
have sent in questions already
um if you've got any questions during
this discussion please send them in
and hopefully john will be able to
answer them
i should just say at the beginning uh
we've made two films this week uh sorry
last week about brexit
one which was looking at uh london's
financial dominance post-brexit
and the other one that was looking at
how brexit has changed the eu
if you want to watch either of those
then click on the i above me and that
will take you
to those links um first of all when you
got the job as brexit editor did you
think you would still be doing it in
october 2019 well when i started um
i assumed that the referendum there
would be a referendum and probably it
would narrowly
be a vote to stay in so i didn't expect
it to go on but as soon as
we knew it was going to be about to
leave it was very clear that it would be
a very complicated
negotiation and it would take many years
well luckily
uh you know everything that's currently
going on or at least i hope so
so saturday was uh quite important it
was very important day
um except the vote that everyone thought
was going to happen didn't happen
can you just tell us a bit about what
was meant to happen what didn't happen
and how it's affecting this week well
boris johnson
had his negotiation on his deal which he
took right up to the
to the wire and indeed concluded only on
the morning of the
eu summit on thursday um and then
persuaded the eu summit to endorse the
deal
which was quite a quite a big
achievement actually many people did not
expect him to get that far
but of course as we've discovered
throughout this process
any deal has to be approved by
parliament and indeed it has to be
legislated by parliament
and theresa may's deal failed three
times in parliament
boris decided after getting his deal he
summoned parliament to a special
saturday session
to get them to approve his deal very
quickly but
mps including mps on his own side don't
trust him completely and they worried
that somehow or other we might still
end up leaving the eu with no deal and
parliament has made clear it doesn't
want that to happen
so what happened on saturday was boris
johnson tries to
have his vote on the deal but suspicious
mps put forward an amendment to say
we're not going to approve this deal now
because we want to see all the
legislation passed first
before approving the deal and that is
the way of stopping
any risk of no deal happening and i know
the dup
changed their mind at the very last
minute and decided to back the blackwin
amendment back the amendment can you
just tell me a bit about why they
decided that what their issue was
what they feel let down by boris johnson
because one key component of his deal
was to say he started out by saying i'm
i don't want any
border border controls on the island of
ireland
and then he said actually i would accept
customs controls between northern
ireland and the republic
uh they would have supported that but
then he was told that's not acceptable
by brussels
and instead dropped that and said no
i'll have controls in the irish sea
between northern ireland and mainland
great britain
and the dep has always wanted there to
be no suggestion of a border and border
controls
between northern ireland and the rest of
the united kingdom so they feel very
let down by boris johnson and that led
them to vote for the for the amendment
to defer
the meaningful vote now today we're
waiting to hear from uh john berko the
the speaker as to whether
there will be a vote today just tell me
what it is that
there might be a vote for and why it may
not happen uh it's
it's called this phrase meaningful vote
it was inserted into the eu withdrawal
act
um in 2018 by a bunch of rebellious
conservative mps
and they said you cannot leave the
european union without
securing a meaningful approval vote in
parliament and they laid out exactly how
that should happen
that was the meaningful vote that
theresa may held in january and then
again in march and she lost each time
she held it the government wanted to do
this on saturday but they were prevented
by
this amendment that was passed so now
that after that they said they'd have
another go
doing it today the speaker is almost
certainly going to say
they can't do it because there is a
long-standing rule that you can't put
the same vote twice
in the same session of parliament so
having tried and failed on saturday they
can't just bring it back and have a go
today
so i don't think it will happen but
there might be a vote tomorrow what
could that vote be on that's on it's a
different thing it's related to brexit
but it is the legislation required
to deliver brexit the withdrawal
agreement bill
which the government is publishing today
and they want to hold
the first it's actually called a second
reading
vote in principle on this tomorrow
and they may even win that but that's
only a first stage in the passage of
legislation and the problem they have in
front of them is that
after that the withdrawal agreement bill
is subject to
amendment and it can be amended by all
sorts of people by the labour party by
rebels by the dup
uh the northern irish and democratic
unionist party
so we'll see a long period of um
amendment and fiddling with
with this legislation and of course once
it's gone through the commons
it's also got to go through the house of
laws um which
you know which means it will take even
longer now that's correct and i mean
the the government boris johnson's plan
is to try and get all this done before
the 31st of october
and it's a very long and very
complicated piece of legislation so to
do it that quickly would be
a remarkable achievement and i think
it's not likely to happen
well let's uh take our first question
here
and we've got one from um annik day
thanks for sending this in
will there be another extension
boris johnson was forced because of what
happened on saturday to to
send a letter to brussels saying please
can we have an extension he was required
by
by the terms of a previous act passed by
parliament to do that
he at the same time sent a letter saying
i don't think it's a good idea
which may have mystified people in
brussels but they have treated it
as a request for an extension and
they're discussing it now because
an extension can be given it has to be
approved unanimously by all
the 27 other eu governments
and i think unless something very
miraculous happens in the next two days
and
and the deal is after all passed by the
houses of parliament which i think is
unlikely
uh there will be an extension because i
think the 27 governments will say they
would prefer to extend this process than
to see britain crash out with no deal
on the 31st of october do you think that
the
um the eu 27 will say
you can have an extension but you have
to have a second referendum or you have
to have an election
they're not they are unlikely judging by
past practice to sort of
start intruding themselves into domestic
politics as it were
but they may well say as they have said
before we we want this extension to be
used for a purpose not just for further
further discussion so it has to be used
either to give effect to all the
legislation to deliver
the brexit deal which is one possibility
or to have some what they sometimes call
democratic event
that might give rise to a position where
the british position changes
and it's either possible to do brexit or
indeed possible to change
change the deal or possibly even to
abandon brexit altogether so they will
expect something to happen
but they won't lay down in two stark
terms what it should be
and that will influence also how long an
extension they give
probably they will give sort of three
three or four months which is the term
that's specified in the
in the parliamentary act but some of
them may want to give longer if they
think there is a chance of having
another referendum
um i just at this point say hello to all
our new joiners
thank you for joining us if you've got
any questions uh please do send them in
i'm joined by john pete today who is the
brexit editor here at the economist
ready to answer any questions you might
have on brexit
um we've got a we've got another
question
um if brexit failed will it mark the
beginning of the fall of right-wing
politics in the uk and europe that's
from abdel-r thank you for sending that
in
uh what do you think to that i i mean
brexit has become the defining political
issue for
for the uk perhaps not surprisingly
because it is a very big
big thing to do um boris johnson has
certainly
staked his political future on getting
brexit done
um if he fails to deliver brexit because
he can't get it through the house of
commons
i think that would have a pretty bad
effect on him and on his party
uh at the same time they are leading in
the opinion polls um so if there's an
election
it's possible he could end up coming
back with a bigger majority than he has
now
but i wouldn't like to predict it
because the opinion polls have been very
up and down all over
all over the place so it's not certain
what would happen do you think there
will be an election
i think that has to be quite soon just
because boris johnson's government
doesn't have a majority and
if you haven't got a majority you can't
really do anything and he's lost almost
every vote he's held in the house of
commons
um i think so i think it would be
logical to say if you can't do that
the way forward is to is to have an
election on the other hand the labour
party is trying to resist an
early election because they think they
might do badly in
in it and their ascent is required
uh under the fixed term parliament's act
for an election to be held
and people don't like having elections
in the middle of the winter so i think
it's quite likely that it'll be next
year rather than this year
but it won't be much longer than that so
sometime in the early part of next year
do you think there's a better chance of
having an election there is of a second
referendum
yes because um the resistance to a
second referendum is quite strong
clearly in the conservative party and in
boris johnson's government they would
resist it very strongly
but quite a lot of labour mps are not
sure they really want another referendum
because
people will say well we've already voted
and you haven't implemented the result
of the first referendum
and now you seem to be asking a second
referendum that seems undemocratic
so i don't think there's a majority for
that in the house of commons but there
will be a majority eventually
to have an election that's interesting
um and i should just also ask you about
boris sending the three letters boris
johnson sending
uh three letters he was going to send
one on saturday night but he actually
sent
three uh just tell me a bit about that
including a photocopy
yes he did and he didn't sign it he was
required by the act to send a letter and
indeed the the act
actually specified what the letter
should say and how it should be set out
and
and he photocopied that and sent it
without signing it and that fulfills in
my view the requirements of the act
although some people are suggesting that
he should be taken to court for not
signing it personally and the court is
looking at it today
the courts are looking into it but i
think that they will decide in the end
it's it's it's
it's okay but he did did then he has
then tried to undermine it
he attacked there was a second letter
which was from the uk
representative in brussels just to say
this letter is attached
and then say but there is a third letter
which we'd like you to read and in the
third letter he said he
actually was personally against an
extension again
some lawyers think that that's that that
could fall foul of of
of the law because it looks as if he was
trying to undermine the first letter he
sent
but in brussels i'm told that they just
treat the first letter as the one that
counts and they're not actually paying
any attention to his
his uh the other two it's quite an
interesting way of trying to deal with
the situation isn't it
um we've got another question here uh
which is
uh what makes the government claim the
uk shall leave on the 31st of october
and
is there confidence justified as you
said boris johnson
makes it very clear that we're going to
we are going to leave
how what how can they be so confident
well i think they're making a mistake
the answer to that i mean when boris
johnson ran for the leadership
he made a great fuss about saying
theresa may his predecessor had delayed
brexit
twice and he thought that was a terribly
bad idea and we should really have come
out
um on the 29th of march which was the
original deadline for for brexit
and he then kept saying it's 31st of
october that is the new deadline and i
it's do or die i'm not going to
allow any further extension and you said
die in a ditch and he said that as prime
minister as well
um the problem is that the stark reality
is that the time has run out
almost perhaps predictably and just to
get all the legislation through now it
makes it very difficult to meet that
31st of october deadline they still
think
they still maintain that it can be done
but it would it would require
the bill the withdrawal agreement bill
to be passed
through all its stages in both houses of
parliament in a week and a half
and the european parliament also to say
yes i think getting both of those things
done in the next 10 days
is highly unlikely um
we've talked a bit about whether it be
an election in
in your eyes what is needed to try and
break this
gridlock i mean we're we're really situ
almost at a situation where we
are still mate it's impossible to go
forwards do you think do you think an
election will help
or do you actually think there needs to
be a referendum another referendum
i'm really not sure what the way forward
is but it is clear there is no majority
for this government in the house of
commons um there isn't a majority for an
alternative
at the moment at any rate um and i think
in that situation it would be logical
at some point hold an election um
probably in the early part of next year
but in a way the the bigger the bigger
risk of that is that it might not solve
anything
um elections are not it will not only be
fought on brexit it won't only be about
whether boris's
boris johnson's deal is a good deal um
it will be about all sorts of other
things
the liberal democrats might do well of
course theresa may had an election
because she wanted to have a bigger
majority in that backfire it failed in
her case so
i it is possible that you'll have an
election and you'll still find that
you're
in a political quagmire and unable to
move forward
and if that were to happen then i think
the pressure of having
another referendum would increase
intensely because people would say we
can't
seem to find no other way out so let's
have a referendum to decide whether we
really want to stay or whether we should
whether we really want to leave or
whether we should change our minds and
stay and in terms of support for the
second referendum
labor of his sort of fa
in favor of it i know that john
mcdonnell spoke at the um people's vote
march on saturday but uh jeremy corbyn
didn't
where do they actually stand on whether
there should be a second referendum or
not
well they've now moved into a position
where they have said any deal should be
put to a second referendum
um and certainly any conservative deal
um
they've also said that even if they were
to form a government
after an election or perhaps by some
other means they would try and strike a
different deal
from boris johnson's with brussels but
they would put that to a referendum as
well
so they're gradually moving towards a
position where they say
any further thought step forward must be
confirmed by a referendum
and we've got a question here from uh
gianluca vartan thank you for sending
your
your uh question in um and to anyone
else
uh who's watching who's got any
questions please do send them in um
which party is most likely to come out
on top following a general election
well the polls do suggest quite strongly
that the conservatives will be the
biggest party
um as they were in the 2017 election um
but
that would be with a fake share of
something like 30 35
and it could even be slightly less than
that whether that produces an overall
majority will depend
very much what would happen to the
liberal democrat vote the social
the the scottish nationalist fate the
green vote and and
of course the labour vote um and some
people have
done the numbers some analysts have
assessed the latest polls and suggested
that boris johnson could end up with a
majority of four or five
well that's not quite a big enough
number to be certain that he will get a
majority at all
and i would not be surprised if we have
an election if it led to another hung
parliament
with the conservatives as the biggest
party could there ever be a coalition
i mean do you think the labour and the
liberal democrats might
form a coalition or with the smp perhaps
it is possible uh indeed sometimes
people say it's possible before
before an election is held they've
talked about a government of national
unity that might be led not by jeremy
corbyn but by some other
leader but with the support of the
liberal democrats um and other parties
and
and some tory dissenters if we have a
hung parliament
i think there will be another parliament
there will be a lot of negotiation about
how a government might be formed it
might be difficult
to do for any other parties and
conservatives to be in that government
if they are the biggest party
but it's not impossible and if labor the
scottish nationalists and the liberal
democrats were to come together and say
we want to form a coalition
of our own they might they might find
that they can they can get a majority
um let's just move on to to another
topic
northern ireland or ireland and northern
ireland um
so uh boris johnson's uh new deal
has taken the irish backstop out and has
replaced it with
sort of an irish front stop can we call
it that or a new
a new way of dealing with a sort of
irish question can you just explain what
it what
what the uh the new deal said well the
deal that theresa may did was
was to include what was called a
backstop
the bax the purpose of the backstop was
to prevent there ever being any hard
border between northern ireland
and the republic of ireland and the way
she was going to do that was to keep the
whole of the united kingdom in a customs
union with the european union that would
mean you wouldn't have to have customs
checks um boris johnson came in saying i
need to remove that backstop that was in
your backstop if we can't find some
other way of dealing with the border
issue
and he has removed the backstop but in
doing so he's replaced it
in a sense with something called a front
stop which is not a fallback position
but actually
what will happen once the deal is
ratified and approved
and the transition period is over and
that will mean that
northern ireland will be in in effect in
a customs union with the european union
but
but great britain will not be and
therefore they have to be customs and
other border checks between
great britain and northern ireland it's
called the border in the irish sea
and which sort of sounds
to try and relax and also it's going to
cause
sorry about that we had a few technical
issues but we are back with you now
and uh i'm joined by uh john pete who's
the brexit editor
here at the economist please keep
sending in your questions and we've
we've got we were just talking about um
ireland and northern ireland and we had
a question
from milan prasad thank you for sending
uh your question then
how will northern ireland react to the
uh the brexit deal to
do boris johnson's latest deal well as
the democratic unionist party
showed they they many people in northern
ireland feel pretty angry with it
because
they see that a border with customs
checks
in the irish sea between northern
ireland and great britain
does to some extent sort of push
northern ireland out
of the united kingdom and towards the
republic and of course some many people
in northern ireland the nationalist
community would quite like the idea of
this being a step towards
towards irish unity um and for that
reason the unionists
are certainly unhappy they did not want
nobody in northern ireland wanted
a hard border between north and south
because that was regarded as something
that would be very bad for the peace
process
um and the security people in northern
ireland were very much against
against having border controls uh
reinstated
along that border but they also don't
want to have a border between northern
ireland
and great britain and that's what boris
johnson is giving them
and they're not happy with that and this
is actually having an effect on scotland
as well be where the
snp wants scottish independence just
tell me a bit about that we've got a
question on this from our community tab
just tell me a bit about how it affects
scotland well it doesn't directly affect
scotland because of course the reason
why northern ireland is in this special
position
is that it's the only part of the uk
that has a land border with
with what will be the european union um
and the republic of ireland
but on the other hand giving northern
ireland a special position of being
inside the customs union with the
european union and taking the rest of
gb great britain out of the customs
union certainly
upsets people in edinburgh because they
like the northern irish the scottish
people voted to stay in the eu
and many of them including nicolas
sturgeon the snp leader are saying if
northern ireland can have this why can't
scotland
and then some people are saying if
scotland and northern ireland were to
have this why can't london
um so this sort of tension about having
the two the two two parts of the united
kingdom having voted to stay in the
european union and the other two parts
having greater to leave
is giving rise to considerable pressure
within the union itself
can you see any solution to how you deal
with the border between
ireland and northern ireland i i don't
see a solution that satisfies everybody
um i mean theresa may's solution was for
the whole of the uk to stay in a customs
union
but that was rejected by many people in
her own party um
and that's why she was replaced and
we've got boris johnson his solution
is to have controls border controls in
the irish sea that's not that but that's
not happy that doesn't sit happily with
those who believe in preserving the
union and it doesn't sit happily
for northern ireland um the only real
answer is that the whole country should
stay in the single market in the customs
union but
conservative brexiteers don't want to do
that if
if they do end up putting the border in
the irish sea do you think that scotland
will
have another independence referendum
what do you think will happen
well i think nicola sturgeon is pushing
towards having an independence
referendum anyway
um because that's what her party
believes in and she
hopes to make gains again if there is a
general election it looks like the
scottish nationalists will do quite well
um they may well take seats from the
conservatives and perhaps from
other parties and after that she would
she will then campaign on the basis that
the scottish people had not just
voted heavily for the snp in a general
election
but they also voted very strongly to
stay in the european union
and they were told in the 2014 scottish
independence referendum
that they shouldn't vote for
independence because it might mean they
ended up leaving the eu
and having to reapply to join and now
she says it's reversed the other way
around they're being forced out of the
eu against their will
so she will certainly be campaigning
very hard to be
to be given another referendum and i
should say and
uh there was a article in the most
recent edition of
the economist that was looking at the uh
referendum on the uh
on scottish independence and if you
click on the i above me that will that
will take you to that
um we're just gonna we've got some
questions that come in um
from our viewers on uh on the kind of
economic impact
of brexit and one is from
juan marago what is the future of the
pound if the brexit deal
goes through well perhaps slightly
surprisingly if it goes through and as
it looked last thursday as if it might
the pound actually
rose on that news but that was primarily
because
currency traders this year have all been
slightly nervous of the possibility that
britain might leave the eu with no deal
at all
which would mean the immediate
imposition of terrorists and other
controls
between um the uk and the eu
they now think that with the deal having
been agreed even though it hasn't passed
through parliament
the chances of a no deal brexit are
smaller than they were
and that's why the pound's gone up but
overall
ever since the referendum the pound has
actually declined
and the reason for that is primarily
because people think that
if and when britain finally leaves the
european union
there will be more friction in trade
between britain and the eu and britain
will be poorer as a result
did they do they rise over the weekend
because of the amendment
yes i think to some extent they raise it
because because they think that all the
signs are
the current parliament will not allow
britain to leave the eu with no deal
but that doesn't mean they're
necessarily they necessarily think that
brexit is a good idea or that boris
johnson's
really quite hard version of brexit is
it will do anything other than quite
serious economic damage to the country
and we've got another one here uh
what are the economic implications of
another delay on the british economy
that's from charles lloyd
the economic implications if it's
delayed again
i i people keep saying it's it's
creating uncertainty and i think that's
true
business would like to know what's going
to happen um but actually
um there has been uncertainty ever since
the brexit
vote um the economy is clearly smaller
today
than it would have been had had the
brexit vote gone the other way
and in the long run because any version
of a deal
like boris johnson's will introduce
barriers um
trade and other barriers between britain
and its biggest market
we are likely to see a somewhat smaller
economy than we would otherwise have
seen
and i think that that is reflected in
business uncertainty
and lost investment investment has
fallen quite sharply over the last um
last two or three years that will
probably continue at some point
britain will find a new sort of way of
trading around the world and maybe we
can regain
regain some of the some of the lost lost
investment that we've had
um and um i should just say at this
point we've we've made a film
that looks at london's financial
dominance
um after brexit so if you uh click on
the i that will
take you to that and another film that
we we have made
is looking at how the eu has changed
since the brexit vote
um and um fabian cameron has sent in
this question
do you think any of european uh of any
of the european countries may benefit
from brexit
and if so which one i'm not sure
i think brexit is basically not a very
good thing for the european union any
more than it is for
for the uk in economic terms but it is
certainly true that places like the
netherlands and france
have gained some company headquarters
companies
who've moved out of out of the uk to con
to the continent
france seems to have gained a little bit
of
financial business that that has shifted
not much but a little bit has shifted
from
out of london which continues to be the
biggest financial center but certainly
some continental centers are trying to
trying to take some of that that
business themselves
um ireland and dublin has also managed
to
get quite a lot of fund managers to move
funds over to over to
um to the republic so there are a few
sectors where i think people feel
they've done slightly better
as a result of the brexit vote than they
would otherwise have done
um let's just move on now to the sort of
looking at the long-term implications
of brexit um we had quite a lot of
questions they were asking about whether
um britain might become a tax haven um
i know that at some point there was a
suggestion that britain might become
like singapore for example
what do you think the chances are of
that actually happening
well i think that's going to be a
subject that will be very heavily
discussed in future negotiations
um what the european union has tried to
do during the last sort of year and a
half of negotiating over brexit
is to say that we would expect the uk
as a very close um country that's close
to us
that is also quite competitive we would
expect them to
stick to most of the rules that they
play that they apply today
but many people in the pro-brexit arm of
the tory party want to actually tear up
quite a lot of these regulations
the eu's response to that is likely to
be to say if you do that
and you go down a road of deregulating
more reducing labor standards reducing
environmental standards
we won't offer you such a generous free
trade deal we'll limit your access to
our markets because they don't they do
fear
a low tax low regulation competitor on
their doorstep
race to the bottom as people are calling
out um
we've got a question here from from bob
uh dunkley
asking what sort of deals could the uk
make with other nations to
to boost their boost their economy after
brexit
well there will be and there certainly
will be an attempt by
if it's the present government or even
the future government to do free trade
deals with with third countries
um uh and obviously people talk
particularly about a free trade deal
with the united states or with china or
with india
and i think that those those talks will
go ahead
um how fast that will be is a very
difficult question
um because experience suggests it takes
a long time to do a free trade deal
they don't usually come for free and
they don't cover all trades how long
does that how long did canada's take
canada's free trade deal with the with
the eu took nine years
um and on top of that it's difficult to
see
free to see it being easy to do a free
trade deal for example is the united
states in particular
because the americans tend to lay down
all the rules that they want to observe
and they don't
take any rules from anybody else and the
mood of actually both parties in america
both the republicans and the democrats
it's not exactly pro-free trade at the
moment
so i think that the gains that are out
there for potential
free trade deals with third countries
are much smaller than some of the
pro-brexit
people claim and what impact
will that have on on our economy after
brexit if
if if it takes a very long time to
negotiate these trade deals
well most of the numbers that have
looked at this suggest that the impact
on the economy of
further free trade deals even with
countries like america china and india
would be quite small
mainly because around half of our trade
britain's trade is with the european
union that is declining slowly
but it's still by far the biggest
trading partner we've got
and if you've introduced as brexit will
do
more friction and more barriers in the
trade relationship with the european
union
the losses you make from that are going
to be far bigger than any gains you can
get from free trade deals with third
countries for quite a long time to come
um i should say this point uh we've got
a lot more people joining so
uh hello to all of you and uh thank you
for joining us please do send in any
questions you might have on brexit
joined by john pete who is the brexit
editor here at the economist
who is answering many of your questions
and and will continue to answer any more
that you send in
and we've got a question here from
maniac singh um
asking about whether brexit will affect
the ongoing u.s china trade war
um i don't think it will have a direct
effect because that's
that is very much a sort of bilateral um
between donald trump and and and the
chinese um
but brexit is one of the factors that is
seen as sort of not benefiting the world
economy at the moment
like the u.s trying to trade war so i
think it plays into what looks like a
sort of slightly gloomier
scenario for the world economy i mean
the imf keeps
down reducing its predictions of growth
and what brexit is one of the reasons
for that
and if we if we do head into recession
if there is a global recession
and and we leave with a deal what will
that impact be
will there you know as opposed to if
there isn't you know there's just a
downturn well in a way i think it may
mean that we
we end up implementing brexit at a time
which is what maximum economic
uncertainty
um and therefore the impact will will
not be helpful
do you think there is an argument to if
even if we are going to leave to deal
to delay it to wait for the global
economy to
no i don't because i think the politics
will trump that but i mean it is true
that it would be it would be better to
do something like this at a time when
the world economy is growing
and the european economy is growing but
it looks at the moment if the world
economy is slowing and the european
economy
is tipping on the on the edge of
recession we've got time just for one
more question
and this one comes from major bison
will europeans apply for uk visas and
vice versa going forward
well the government has said that they
will end free movement of people
which means the the right of any
european union citizen to
to come and live and work here so they
will introduce a new regime
which would mean that if you wanted to
come and work here from continental
europe you may well have to apply for
some kind of work permit or visa
it won't affect normal tourism or normal
travel because
rather as between most eu countries in
the united states you can do that
with some other in some other way some
electronic way of doing it
so i think people will still be
traveling but it will certainly affect
the world of work
thank you thank you very much and we're
going to leave it there
uh thank you so much to everyone who's
joined us thank you for sending in your
questions
and we're going to put this video up on
our channel so you'll be able to watch
the
the whole q a session with john
um later on today we will be back with
another live q a
at some point hopefully next week um
thank you very much for joining us
and it's going to be an interesting week
it's a busy week a busy week thank you
bye